if you find this video informative
please hit the like button and please
subscribe to my channel for more videos
like this in this video we will be
studying the waltz visual cycle before
discussing the actual cycle let us have
an overview about what happens in this
cycle as you all know the human eye
contains two main types of
photoreceptors the first is the rods and
secondarily cones the basic structure of
rods is as follows these are the atoms
and this is the nucleus now it contains
the disks which have the pigment
rhodopsin the basic step in the walls
visual cycle is that when the rhodopsin
is exposed to light it forms an
intermediate compound known as meta
rhodopsin to which further breaks down
into opsin and 11 says retinol this
metal rod option to which is formed
through generation of various enzymes it
triggers the nerve impulse now let us
look at the details of the wall visual
cycle so the first step in the visual
cycle is the exposure of zero Doctson
collide which causes it spray it down
into luminaire drops in this lumen
rhodopsin spontaneously converts into
metal rhodopsin 1 which further converts
into metal rhodopsin - now this metal
rod opsin 2 gives two compounds the
first is the option and second is the
old trans retinal now this all trans
retinal has to be converted back into
elevenses retinal so that it can combine
with the opsin and lead to the
reformation of rhodopsin this conversion
occurs through two main pathways the
first
which operates in the eye the ultras
retinol is converted into elevenses
retinol by the enzyme retinol isomerase
and this elevenses retinol combines with
opsin and forms rhodopsin the second
pathway which operates is in the liver
now here the enzyme is the alcohol
dehydrogenase the first the ultras
retinol is converted into all-trans
retinal and this is converted by the
enzyme isomerase to eleven sayst red
node which is acted upon again by the
alcohol dehydrogenase and converted into
eleven sis retinol now the next
important thing to know is how the nerve
impulse is generated to the cycle
now the question which arises here is
how does meta rhodopsin lead to
generation of normal pulse for
understanding this let us understand how
the various ion channels are distributed
on a rod cell this is the axon and these
are its terminal knobs and this is the
nucleus the first major type of the ion
channels which are located in the rod
cells are the sodium potassium ATPase
bound the main function of this pump is
to pump out the sodium ions and pump in
the potassium ions this creates a state
of electro negativity inside the rod
cells another major type of the ion
channel are the uncatted potassium leak
channels through this ions the potassium
ions content constantly leak out and
create a state of electro negativity
another ion channels are the gated
sodium channels through which there is a
constant entry of the sodium inside the
rod cell now this entry creates a state
of electronegativity of minus 40
millivolts which is much less as
compared to minus eighty millivolts of
other excitatory cells now here are the
calcium channels through which theory
are there is constant entry of the
calcium inside the axon and through the
terminal knobs there is the release of
the glutamate now this metal rhodopsin 2
causes activation of a regulatory
protein known as transition this
transition causes activation of the
enzyme phosphodiesterase this
phosphodiester enzyme causes the
conversion of cyclic GMP - pi - G and B
and the concentration of the cyclic GMP
decreases due to this step now since the
cyclic GMP is essential for the opening
of the gated sodium channels due to the
decrease in the CMP concentration the
sodium channels closed and this leads to
the decreased entry of sodium in there
are cells and their concentration
decreases since there is a constant
influx of potassium ions through the
lead channels there is excess negativity
inside the cells and this leads to the
hyper polarization of the rod cell this
hyper-polarization causes the closure of
the gated calcium channels now since
this calcium is essential for the
release of the glutamate through the
terminal knobs the release of the
glutamate stops and due to the decrease
in the release of the glutamate there is
the generation of the electric potential
in the bipolar cells and for the
conductance follows